hey reject nation Greg Alba here John we
are gonna watch the day from screen
junkies honest trailers the honest
trailer this for Jurassic Park 3 I like
doing the reactions for these because
they have a segment on screen junkies
news honest trailers commentary I kind
of feel like our review part is a
version of honest trailers commentary by
the way it was on movie fights a few
weeks ago go check that episode before
we do that Jurassic Park monsters mayhem
at Universal Universal home
entertainment has sent us a box for a
Pacific Rim uprising and I thought I'd
be fun to do two videos and one so
before we hop on to the reaction for
honest trailers Jurassic Park 3 we are
gonna do an unboxing video Universal
home entertainment in association with
Gamefly for a Pacific Rim uprising all I
did is save time was I cracked open the
box have not looked inside this box just
yet real quick Pacific Rim uprising if
you did see our review for the movie we
actually really enjoyed it I personally
preferred it more than the first one I'm
excited to see what's inside this box
alright ooh
[ __ ] Avenger toy i have a big
collection of toys that are right over
here that I constantly glare at to
remind myself of my success in life so
that's gonna be added to the list right
here at cool [ __ ] Avenger toy awesome
just like Kirby Jones's dog than right
here of course a copy of Pacific Rim
uprising in 3d what we're gonna have to
upgrade that TV you get a 3d line right
here I'm excited to own this one because
I actually do prefer more than the first
one not just saying that because they
sent us this nifty box if you watch our
reveal content Oh a copy of Pacific Rim
I prefer this more than Pacific Rim
Uprising I'm not just saying that cuz
they sent me the box this is the best I
do prefer this I've seen this one like
three times though I have wait this
feels like a book what is it like the
art of it is the art oh okay
art and making a Pacific Rim uprising
Wow well between John and I I am
definitely the one who will not prefer
this one here you go I sure thought you
were going to take it oh this is more my
jam pins you got all them right here
yeah okay here we go I feel all you
shirts what did they take care of us
okay but since you get the thing I
wanted most yeah the DVD I wanted yes I
get to choose this shirt all right I've
clearly made out this video
all right first one first morning you
guys will see it before me I can't see
oh is it oh oh like the emblem okay yeah
okay this is this is the shirt you wear
to the gym when people go did you work
on the movie yeah this is your like
Jaeger army t-shirt that they give you
when you would list but you lost some
retrofit for the lease punching you in
the glasses it's okay so camel warrior
gene so some of the view fighting I'm
called that I call this shirt I call
this shirt okay hey the one that shows
you worked behind the Pacific legendary
boom Shakalaka awesome it's a really
sweet gift bag some man locks and they
think Oh gate with six month Gamefly
membership gaming we're all about that
night and I know about me three weeks
sweet oh thanks game fly at Universal
home entertainment yeah well awesome
thank you guys for all these goodies
cific from uprising is now out I think
as of today yeah I'm not mistaken it
just came out cuz I keep up to date with
all DVD releases
going to my collection right here some
awesome pins that I will put on my cap
thumb through this book tonight I wish
it I could draw or concept design as
well as good as any of these people well
let's keep the universal and monster
mayhem continuing with an honest
trailers for easily the best of the
Jurassic s-- Jurassic Park 3
one two three today's episode is brought
to you by the US Army and Universal home
entertainment game flaw they welcomed
you to Jurassic Park
then they welcomed you to the lost world
now the franchise just kind of wears out
its welcome in
director Park we're watching Jurassic
Park at last I see the fifth Jurassic
movie we visit the chapter that made
these movies go extinct for 50 years
combining of the ashpod meaning two
islands of antimatter to score the
lowest critical response of the series
the universal of just listen to Jeff
Goldblum they were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could then you start
to think of a shot
Sam Neill returns as Indiana Jones - all
charisma and it's great thing about
bones and a run away with that's the
most met a roll of his career as he
plays a guy pressured by fans and it
going back does anyone have a question
that does not relate to Jurassic Park
who finally gives in because of a
paycheck characters like Billy who
carries a parachute on land for the
entire movie just in case the mandatory
Jurassic Park child of divorce takes may
see as a timid paint salesman who scams
a team of mercenaries and kidnaps dr.
grant to rescue his kid from a hotshot
who's dating his wife huh I think if
they told the story from his perspective
this movie might actually be good is
t-rex P never mind because this movie
ruins every last one of them killing off
the t-rex in seconds
just to show how badass the spinosaurus
is weirdly obsessing over the Raptors
vocal cords to remember the sounds they
made and making the dinosaurs birth
shaking loud but still has them sneak up
on people like Teflon clad ninjas yeah
so gear up for the most forgettable
Jurassic Park movie that we ought to be
here any antagonists forgot to say any
of the credit or an actual ending for
gothic with the phrase oh my god into
the script nine different times
[Music]
no he's not haha my god that's lazy ah
storage never get solid passionless
tailor t-rex this prize let me put you
on hold over a minute ah all over
themselves
well can you blame them
this would loss a raptor on a plane the
one where a dinosaur says go and pretend
this whole movie is a dream prequel to
the lego video game today's episode was
real yeah was by clicking the link below
Alan and when everybody has an awesome
voice no one will I didn't choose the
honest trailer live last night we
watched the original Jurassic Park
decided this week I'm gonna watch
Jurassic Park Jurassic world and then
watch Jurassic world falling Kingdom on
Thursday just so I could hate your ass
honest trailer reminding me so much of
why I was more than okay with what
Jurassic world gave us Jurassic world
has a fanbase for sure and then a lot of
people hate it you know cuz I feel like
a lot of the installments after the
first one you just hate because none of
them match up to the greatness that is
the first one this is the lowest I think
it's way lower than drastic world for
sure I like Jurassic world this is awful
and there's something in here that I'm
kind of surprised they didn't point out
one of the main reasons I have a strong
distaste for this movie the fact that
they completely obliterate the entire
art of Sam Neal's Dr Grant character in
the first one one of the beautiful
character arcs in the first movie dr.
grant hates kids ending note is he's
holding the kids and he's looking at
them like no we should have someone
there's get back to the baby-making when
we get home off this island and then in
part three it does that thing where
they're not dating anymore she's married
as someone else has kids with someone
else I kind of respect the idea of
Neels characters just so traumatized
from the events and maybe this story is
somewhat of a play on him facing his
trauma or whatever others ruin his life
I hate how they obliterated that whole
arc I would have much rather it's like
if you're gonna bring back Laura Dern
there's no point in including her at
this point if you're gonna completely
wipe away that whole arc that they had
in the first one it's just like look we
see we did it we checked the box and
like nothing nothing beyond that I don't
know which honest trailer writer decided
to use that line from Jeff Goldblum in
the first one my favorite moment in the
first movie is when the scientists and
are all at the table with John Hammond
they're talking about whether or not
this Jurassic Park idea is a good idea
and using that line from Ian Malcolm I
think was so preoccupied with whether or
not they could think of this is a great
writing I gotta point that out that the
idea of taking that line and separating
this honest trailer is so brutally that
is a universally relevant line and it is
a perfect line for this particular
scenario and arguably this sequel the
most yeah and also there are commentary
on dr. Graham's character being
pressured to go back to the island
because of fanboys doing it for a
paycheck that was yeah maybe this is the
reason why Sam Neill is the star of this
movie so when they also pointed out that
there is kind of no antagonist aside
from just like incidental dinosaurs and
and the movie really does sort of have a
meandering quality to it yeah as of that
you know it does feel like it like it's
sort of a random installment even in
just the way the set up is lost world
introduces some pretty goofy elements
[Music]
this amps up the lowbrow humor the whole
degree you know like Alan bit they keep
referencing with the Raptor just the
overall comedy in this film is just so
so bad it it feels like a made-for-tv
movie it really does and I saw this for
the first time like a year or two ago
and I was kind of shocked at the tone
just the overall like production values
in the tone you got Ned Flanders walking
around - which I'm so glad nobody made a
joke about I hate that Tea Leoni is
shouting so much in this movie if I
remember the movie correctly it's been a
few years since I've seen it but dr.
Gregg gets knocked out he wakes up
William H Macy and Auntie Leone are
shouting on a speakerphone further son
how stupid characters you know where you
are that was more my main takeaway is
how loud and thick all of the main
characters except for dr. grandpa yeah I
felt so bad for him watching this movie
because it's like oh you must just have
a headache this is a really challenging
movie to actually sit through I don't I
don't even enjoy it in a sense of it's
so bad it's good to me it's kind of an
annoying film there are some cool
dinosaur like I forgot that like the
Spinosaurus is cool yeah even though
yeah that whole thing we're like sneaks
up on them is totally ridiculous
especially with like the way every
Jurassic Park movie makes a point of
going look out heavy their footsteps
see the first movie is a great science
fiction horror film and that's why my
favorite scene is when they're having a
debate about whether or not this is a
good idea cuz the writing is so rich
with treating the characters as if what
if this really happened how would these
characters discuss this situation it's a
great scene the rest are kind of just
franchised out money-making machines
that's the whole point of them when they
shift into being adventures more than
they do sci-fi or horror really the
issue that I have with Jurassic Park 3
above all of them is they're a zero
style to the way the movies done the
lost world at least has a few redeeming
moments I think I think that scene
when the two t-rexes and they're in the
vans or whatever that is a great
sequence it's scary
there's a few other moments that are I
think are genuinely thrilling and
genuinely good and at least bill Berg is
trying something and there's still a
spill bird direction to it and a good
score heart for and definitely has style
you know whether or not you like the
style of the fourth one it has a style
this movie is bland that's the my
biggest issue with it you look at these
shots just what they're shown in this
honest trailer with so many sequences of
that like even that scene with Gio Leone
where they make the joke about her
screaming because she sees the parachute
it's just this like boring stagnant shot
where it just seems like plant the
camera here we don't have a budget
because Phil Berg didn't return for this
this one out of them all feels like the
one where the studio cared the least
about it it is and thought about just
cashing on some brand-name cheesy
effects the one thing that could have
made up for it all how like half of this
film is at least try doing something
stylistic with the way you're shooting
this oh yes so many of these kinds of
movies can get a pass with some cool
shots and whatnot and I was thinking
like if you just watch this honest
trailer with the sound off I think the
only things that would look enticing are
the few moments where dinosaurs show up
in the rest of it yeah
doesn't really grab your eye that much
that's the funny thing is like a lot of
honest trailers make me kind of morbid
curiosity you want to go back and like
rewatch that and see like not only that
bad but this one I don't even want to do
that this is not a good film and I think
it's definitely the lowest one of them
all some people argue that at least this
film knew what it was I don't think so
this is the definition of the film going
they don't care yeah I wish you are at
least use that to your advantage
thank you screen junkies for putting
together an amazing honest trailer I
think you too universal home
entertainment and Gamefly or giving us
this awesome Pacific Rim goodies monster
mayhem continues well you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Belka subscribe
buttons are essentially broken and you
can check us out on patreon full-length
TV show reactions weekly Q&A zyk video
coverage would love to have you you you
become a patron eject today